yeah what can we do this video hit
another black game okay play if I fun to
see what happens Poland is from
Argentina yeah let's play the Schliemann
didn't play this for a long time feels
like a long time at least III young dee
threesome a good a simple way to to play
this castles yeah Bishop C fibers the
normal way you can also play d6 actually
Bishop c5 this is gambit now maybe let's
try out try out t6
of course them the bishop is restricted
but on the other hand we are not
sacrificing a pawn and you still have
this half open a file which is the main
accomplishment here in the in this line
of the slimmin because it's an extra
center poland you sometimes can can get
really good play on the FR yup let's see
how do i get get castle now I play
Knight e5 maybe or is this completely
completely strange okay maybe this is a
way to to get castle
if I castle now before night black
Bishop c4 check yeah yeah I can do those
things but I hope they don't lead to
much
maybe yeah who this is a very direct way
to to go about that hmm not sure if it
is a good way but where to go
interesting question i can go to a 5 or
to bada to sell not ridiculous i go to
pho why not be five is not exactly
helping am on the queenside let's try to
block the queenside
mmm yep the num I want to take this
Queenie 67
yeah yeah this probably wasn't so great
if I've I mean white is white is in good
shape now not easy if or anything or
winning off but what looks looks better
here I have a bit of private problems to
to to to make a to making a constructive
moves maybe wicker sevens oh I like that
at least I get my pieces out here yeah
this is a transformation that I am that
I that I had seen it looks good for
white but it's not not an immediate
problem 96 so that it covers see [ __ ]
porn and the prepare night descended
Bishop g5 if I get the dark squared
Bishop off then I should be in decent
shape
the question is is there some direct
technical threat
yeah 97 I was very close to just
blundering this Bishop great okay
Vincent protected ok yeah I need to put
this I don't know you take now
I understand that it looks like
temporarily it looks very nice for white
but you got you eat boy yeah well night
CC the 97 I could could just drop back
ok kappa this and then next move from
something to f6 don't know what exactly
maybe the bishop even
hmm I thought rook everyone attending
wook f7 then the cam later now yeah
maybe Knight f6 Knight f6 looks better
at all temporarily it looks nice for
white good you have some problems as
well efore is potentially week a4 is
potentially week 2 nite c 5 and then
you're not well very well coordinated if
you would have better huh what this
would surprise me this would be the
right solution now night c5 attacks a
484 now this is good enough for black
his weaknesses are simply easier to
attack maybe you can play night III yeah
this is interesting I hope that this is
good now
yep I want to go here now cannot take it
because of the e74 but i can try to play
king f7 and improve the position of this
one this is this is stronger even just
attacking you form check yeah night
reform night before or can I take you
for now is this is this problem
check
check-check
yeah just um can I win this sometime
time warning check check yeah probably
you mates me game drone or deck and you
should have won the song position sorry
yeah overlook night reform and this
position blackshot just win he's got
that too many weaknesses here look f
eight is good okay yeah I didn't I
didn't really see this this archaic and
just take it I can just take it idiotic
yeah I can just take it okay yeah it's
not like it great or anything but this
is what I should do this is some an end
game yeah probably a very good and game
he cannot exchange that a phone phone so
probably needs to keep the book on
something like this year this I can play
for on forever with an extra porn not
sure if I should win probably not what
I'm sorry I can I can play them play
this on forever yeah and I'm always with
unsure what I should do at the end in
those type situations because I'm I
really don't like to to play this on
time
if you if you just resign those games
all the time you also feel silly because
nobody ever gives you a draw in a
similar situation vice versa who I'm
sorry I need it something to drink
thanks for watching